[Music]
your gramma be swirling campaign and
mid-september this year and it was borne
out of a conversation in the office
actually about how terrible my team felt
when we when we've been bullied and we
started this conversation of like what
about all these people with millions of
followers who get this every single day
on how much they feel how do I go bed in
the morning how do they cope although we
absolutely love social media this is
definitely a darker side of it and it's
a phenomenon that doesn't seem to be
going away so we hope tonight to have a
really great request conversation about
ways that we can improve the beautiful
in conversation so to introduce our
panel properly this is Callie Rowena
so Carly is one of the UK's leading
personal trainers and champions of body
positivity with an active audience of
millions watching her videos each month
and Kylie who as you might have noticed
it's eight months pregnant it's more
actually anyone ready to deliver with
her first child and she actually led
Glamour's blend up bullying campaign
where she gave readers an insight into
the negative comments messages she was
he has received during her pregnancy I
mean he would control a pregnant woman I
mean it's just not right is it the video
received unprecedented praise with over
70,000 views and hundreds of positive
comments the main thing Kylie gets
trolled about is currently it's for
exercising while pregnant and damaging
her bathe beyond being accused of
damaging her baby and putting her ABS
before her pregnancy then next we have
link Katie link is a beauty influencer
and digital entrepreneur with over 1.2
million followers on Instagram she's
attracted a cult following for her
honest insightful and yet eternally fun
blogs about skin hair cosmetics and
style and she's a member of the L'Oreal
beauty squad and will be hosting her
first of a masterclass at Spectrum
collections this month next we have Josh
newest Smith who I've got the pleasure
of working with every day
Glamis celebrity and entertainment
editor and presents his own popular
YouTube blog joshing tonneaus Josh's
blog takes a fresh and unique look
everything from latest trend advice to
fashion makeovers as well as dynamic
celebrity interviews you won't find
anywhere else I can go into you he's
done everything for us for glamour from
exclusively interviewing Reese
Witherspoon and Oprah to going backstage
of the Victoria Beckham at New York
Fashion Week and hitting Victoria's
Secret Show with Bella Hadid next up we
have Megan Barton Megan's a model who
recently found fame on ITV's love Island
and since Megan's departure from the
show she's graced the covers of Grazia
and OK Magazine Megan is now focused on
building her career as a model presenter
and advocate for women's rights good for
you and using her platform to raise
awareness around issues such as female
equality and empowerment our kind of
girl let's start let's let's talk beauty
bullying bullying full stop used to be
in the playground or in the workplace
very much in person and then the last
few years it's it's gone online and it's
evolved into something nasty and larger
than ever before how do you feel
personally and this is to all of you
that person that bullying story in
person is different to bullying online
we'll start with you Carly
I think the thing I found when it's
online I was then expected I was really
lucky I grew up pretty internet which
makes me sound really old so anything
that happened to me at school when I was
growing up just it was at school it
didn't go anywhere else but when you
kind of get to the stage now where you
have this amazing platform and people
that you feel kind of like your online
family and friends and then you just get
this like small percentage that are just
kind of grilling you for everything
whether it is positive or just a natural
picture and you you're not expecting it
and it does hurt and then annoyingly
it's the one whether you get amazing
comments the one negative one is the one
that you listen to the most it's the one
that stays with you that whole day
especially if you're just not feeling
like you've got your forcefield up yet
and I think now you know online is
something everybody has so we're all
victim to it at any point at any point
your day and it depends with your having
a good or a bad day as to how much it's
going to hurt you I feel like growing up
in school I was buried really really
badly
but I was able I was so lucky because I
had teachers that I could trust that
could help support me with that so they
were the ones who helped me stop the
billion but because of social media what
can I do I literally can't do nothing
the only thing I can do is like they
comments I think on my page I think it's
in the air and straight away I'm flying
but in school it was just so different
and so now it's like every day is a bit
of a struggle to like ignore it and one
comment can really like bring down my
mood and you know I do try my best to
like tell myself just stay strong don't
worry about they don't know who you are
you've got so many people who like you
for you but it is a real struggle and
that is that one is true like that's the
only way I can really explain oh do you
think there is a difference between
being bullied at school by people you
know and then complete strangers you
don't know where they are Billy's
believe me in school we ended up
becoming friends and I can't be friends
with these people online because it's
just so much texting you I know right
like so much things to worry about and
it's like you know sometimes the people
who believe me
a lot of them they just don't want to
open their mindset they just don't want
to like listen to my side of this story
they just don't want to understand me as
a person and it's like you know part of
me is the reason why I started my own
YouTube channel so people can see me so
they know that I'm not trying to put a
front on or anything like this is me and
a happy excited person and so people
just don't get it and it's just so hard
for me to understand how these people
exist
well beauty like bullying and it South
has kind of evolved quite strangely for
me because I got bullied when I was at
school for being gay news flash and but
the thing what I found really empowering
by getting bullied in real life is once
I met myself that I was actually a young
gay boy and some would say to me you're
gay you're this like what like I know
and once you could face it in that way I
found it quite empowering and then it
kind of evaporated and it you know it
comes up every day in the street
sometimes and that to be honest affects
me more than when that happens to me
online because we since I've been doing
YouTube it can be very savage like I've
had someone write comments saying you
deserve to be locked up in prison raped
every day where you belong extreme stuff
and it's because I just see it's like a
very faceless person that obviously
using I mean YouTube is a platform where
you don't have to necessarily have a
profile your names attached to you you
can do it faceless you can really go in
and I feel like it's a community that
can be really empowering but it also be
very hateful at the same time for me
I've always use social media quite
heavily even before love Ireland
Oh doula glamour model in so all my
Instagram is where I got most of my work
most of people like discovered me via
Instagram and then it was more like
comment and they would have something to
say they'll be like oh you're a slag
you're getting your tits out and then
the next message below oh but I'd love
to do this this and this too so it's
like I kind of took that with a pinch of
salt something like okay you can't win
but for me the hardest thing is women
like attacking each other and tearing
each other down yes I've had surgery yes
I'm like sexually empowered I've had sex
on TV I'm not ashamed of that but why as
women can't me stand together and be
like well this is Megan's choice yes
she's had surgery I want necessarily do
it I went date as many guys she's dated
but just because I've done it doesn't
mean that I'm a bad person and I've
still got good songs I for me it's just
sad to see other women's hair women down
I think we should all like stick
together so that was of
women yeah like throughout my life I've
always been quite shy and I think it's
easy present if you're a bit quiet and
shy Billy's will love that they'll make
Mike's anything back and so yeah but for
me it's like worse since love island I
think if one person jumps on it and it
could be anything like the tiniest thing
so I've got a really chubby thumb one's
normal one's chubby people M slated me
for a thumb like come on can we just
live like it's a thumb leave the ports
on my lap and they've met one person job
- oh my god Jer did you hear that let's
go in comment about this so it's mad
it is really mad what people like will
jump on and thrive off of and the way I
look at it these people aren't happy if
you're happy you'll go out and if your
life you won't like sit behind a screen
with no profile picture make a fake
account and then try and drag someone
else down it's a particular thing that
you've been trolled for Wow Oh
everything my race the shape of my face
just everything it was my skin like two
years ago I had really bad acne but I
learned so love there and even though
when I was doing my makeup videos
because it was makeup on acne everyone
immediately seems oh my god you put
makeup on your acne singing is like your
skin my skin is foreign like yes I have
acne but I'm using really good products
to help get rid of it and then today is
like I love my skin so much but these
other people don't for me and I just
find that we use it about your pumps
it's a really bad deed does it really
affect you that much
so yeah that's what really affected me
it's mostly two years ago is my skin but
now it's like now it's just me as a
person but apparently that's a bad thing
yeah yeah and then because I'm like so
excited I'm so well five moves about
this young girl thousands of pounds of
my skin trust me like loads of facials
over the years
yeah because well I'm not gonna lie the
reason why I spent so much money on my
skin whist because of the hateful meds
which is it kind of makes me look like
oh she's kind of weak but that is the
truth it's like yeah I think not nervous
to have me into it I mean if someone
says horrible things about you look in
the mirror and you sometimes hear you
hear that noise and you see that things
over and over again and it got to the
point where as soon as I'd wake up when
I had acne really bad acne I think that
I'd wake up I run to the mirror and pray
that was gone it got to that point I'm
like even though half of me was like
Ling it's fine it's just act nice I
don't acne it's gonna go away a part of
me was like oh you have to film a video
I'm so many people gonna see and they're
gonna say something about it and it's
just like it can be really hard
yeah I mean I'm stopped exercising while
you're pregnant yeah they're mine yeah
might started after I announced that I
was pregnant and I've always exercised
it's been in my life I loved doing it so
um it was it was a small percentage but
it's enough that they were hurtful and
people were saying that I was gonna lose
my baby I'm killing my child
and yeah that I was choosing like abs
and exercise over the health of a baby
which is I do exercise a lot but I'm
doing less than I was before naturally
and I'm trained and qualified I deal
with clients that are pregnant and for
me that hour where I'm working out feels
the best in the day and if I was you
know throwing up or something was wrong
I wouldn't go and exercise I'm not silly
but I think for me I thought I hadn't
taken on board and I remember going for
my 20 week scan which is the one where
they can tell you if it's like a boy or
a girl we didn't find out that and when
I got home I just projectile vomited and
I was really lucky the whole pregnancy
Hanuman's
and I realized that actually these
people are telling me that I was gonna
lose it had actually really affected me
and for that day I think had panicked
that maybe something was wrong but
actually I had you know done something
because everyone's telling me that I'm
gonna lose it and when I got home I was
just so sick for a good couple of hours
and it just built up and it's really
hard to not listen to that and so
weirdly a lot of it was Instagram dm's
and people were actually emailing me
they weren't really putting it on me at
my pictures and mainly YouTube was
getting a lot of them because again you
don't have to have a face whereas I
think with Instagram and I'm not as big
on Instagram people couldn't know I
probably see it and I could go onto
their profiles so it was kind of this
sort of hiding it behind which was
really was really tough but over it and
I kind of I spoke out about it and I
used this campaign as well and people
did start to realize that what they're
saying it's just awful but I think a lot
of its calmed down now because I'm
coming to the end of it they're like oh
well the baby's still there but now I
think I'm probably gonna get it from
another way which will be after the
pregnancy does she get her body back or
you know that kind of stuff and it's not
what you really want to focus on oh my
god so - I actually was discussing this
my housemate a couple of days ago
because I did a video and I looked and I
went oh my god it hasn't got any
homophobia on it and I was shocked and
it honestly that moment I was like this
is actually kind of scary that that is
the rule and not the exception
whereas you know you obviously get
people being like lucky this is so funny
you're hilarious bla bla bla bla bla but
you will literally keep scrolling and
scrolling a scrolling down which you see
the hateful comment and you're literally
please like and you go and you feel
angered by it but I went through so many
different phases where I was like this
makes me feel so horrible about myself
maybe I should change myself maybe I
should tie myself down but then actually
I used it to become like an empowerment
thing and I was like if you hate it I'm
gonna do it hard and I'm gonna be more
in your face and like also just click on
another video that's how I just always
think when I see it I'm just like
there's a space for everyone on social
media there's a space for some of them
Instagram is a space for someone on
YouTube I just don't see why you have to
go out your way to do it but it's gone
from
being about homophobia to them being
about my visual appearance like I used
to have like quite bad teeth along the
bottom line used to call my teeth like
my nanny mcphee it wasn't that bad that
wasn't like Emma Thompson Nanny McPhee
I used to make a joke about I mean
knowing that to feed tooth is out and
then people would literally especially
in YouTube's very big in America
obviously but they would and obviously
they have massive massive very
preconceived notions of what dentistry
should look like so they will always be
like your teeth are disgusting you
should get your teeth fixed
why isn't boy got his teeth fixed and
you would see it would be the same
people again and again and again and
again again I'm like God you guys got so
much time I wish I had this much time to
trial not that I would obviously trial
but you know what I mean but I just
found it crazy and I actually did then
get braces because of it but that was
that wasn't necessarily because it was a
response to a hater is more an
insecurity that I had because like he
was saying earlier about do you look in
the mirror and you see it yes I can look
in the mirror and I can see it and it is
something that plays onto my mind I
think the worst thing is when it taps
into an insecurity that you already have
I think I'm fine with being gay whatever
like I can't change that so like what
you can say whatever you like but you
can say something about my vision
parents and sometimes I will literally
look on YouTube videos and I have like a
Julius Caesar nose and I will look at it
and be like oh my god I hate that frame
of my nose and then someone's gonna and
I actually think someone's gonna troll
me for it which is a crazy thing because
you should be allowed to like live your
best Roman nose life if you want to and
you shouldn't feel like you should have
to have a nose like that but I think
it's a hard and it's a very savage
Savage play social media sometimes Megan
if you changed anything about yourself
as a result of the hate the first
cosmetic surgery I had was getting my
ears pinned back so I guess that was
because of like kids in the playground
they'll be like taking the piss out of
me but more for myself like you say if
it's something on your face like acne or
like your teeth every day when you wake
up and got a look at yourself in the
mirror and for school you get up and
your mum's like cow bed get outta bed I
have two minutes put my hair back I
don't want to put my hair back and have
these massive ears like it made me feel
but I didn't do it for anybody else so I
guess it adds to the pressure when you
go just go on in like
when you've got an insecurity and then
kids will be like taking the piss a bit
more so it does add but I think I'm very
selfish and very stubborn so I'll just
do it for me that's the thing I never
planned to go on a reality show and
people always slightly for having
surgery because these young girls will
look up to you but when I made these
decisions and then I didn't do it for
anyone else other than me I didn't think
I'm gonna go on a reality show all these
young girls will go to their surgery but
I like Megan but if it wasn't me and I
didn't have surgery it'll be someone
else in the public eye Angelina Jolie
Kyle Egypt like there's always someone
so I think you've got being a little bit
selfish
that's what I done but for me it's
mainly the surgery and being fake and
then being a slack because I had sex on
TV and I was a glamour model and a
stripper so yeah I mean did you reduce
the amount of exercise you were doing at
all because of the hate or did you
obstinate as well as I didn't reduce the
amount of exercise I think I reduced
what I said which made me sad because it
always been so honest online and I did
find myself thinking I'm just maybe not
gonna post it this time but do you know
what the same thing happened that she
was thinking when you guys talked about
this before I was pregnant I had quite
visible abs I got hate for those people
told me I look like a man for them so
people were never ever happy no matter
what I had and so and I remember then I
used to try and not do an ab workout so
that my abs would maybe go away but that
was where I've got to with my body so I
think it does affect you because you
just know that they're gonna think what
you've probably always been worried
about but I have to say with every kind
of year that you grow up you do kind of
just go this is just [ __ ] and I'm
not taking anymore so yeah I ended up
posting at all and now I think I
actually do write well this one will be
for a little bit like people that have
like a foot fetish now I'm like he'll
this is for the foot fetish people my
feet are gonna go on there more I hope
you just kind of end up going fine I'll
share it and you just know it's gonna
come but I think if you're anticipating
it and you're kind of going about it a
bit like well fine then it's good but
you do have to get to that point we all
and Bradys just take it on do you think
this is just an amine sorry I know
you're a man but do you think it's just
another form of woman bashing motherhood
sexuality do you think this is just a
new form of it
Wow I had some things my friend was on
the train and she literally had to
fourteen-year-old girls on the train
saying oh I can't wait to go home it's
like in lecture on YouTube yeah like
it's like a hobby like is that actual
hobby like oh this is my career like
this it goes through their heads and I'm
just I think it's just life right now
like 14 year to 14 year old girls really
it's like to go home to troll on other
people's accounts it's gotten that deep
and this is not that I'm so glad glamour
is talking about cyberbullying because
what many people are but something was
scared and some people think that they
talk about it is not gonna be recognized
enough so I'm so glad I'm able to
actually share it with you guys because
it's shocking it's real shocking
behavior and I hope one day schools can
talk about cyber billion as well as
billion on a playground because back in
the day when there was Bebo I also got
trolled as well and I think that was
like the beginning when social media
platforms started developing and makes
me you know YouTube and the next thing
you know you can make a career out of
social media it's just a verbs and it
just became more and more aggressive
so I think the invisibility do you think
I mean you know sexual double standards
is nothing new we've had it since the
beginning of time as I said do you think
it's just the invisibility and the
unanimity of people that gives them the
courage to then say say these things to
you I think not eat for not unlike
Instagram YouTube you don't have to put
a profile picture you can just set up
account in a matter of minutes go on to
someone that you don't like if you're
having a bad day and like try and drag
them down just because you're not
feeling so good and that's what I try
and tell myself because it does sting it
does hurt when you get these negative
comments but I think the person making
its fake account and spending their time
I had an essay the other day sayin to me
about what a slug I was that I was
deserves better and then the same girl
message was and said oh you do really
like she's going to cheat on you get out
now while you can
blah blah blah and I think really it's
her who should be feeling sad
she's obviously really unhappy in her
life that she has to take time out to
write essay to the both of us surely
it's things like more about her than me
but it is it's bright like it gives
people a chance to be brave but I'm not
saying it to your face
I've never once touchwood had any hate
in person and it's always been on like
social media you've said to me lassie
you were shocked at the difference
between the hate you and weres got for
the same thing he's my boyfriend I don't
want him to get any like hey it's all he
doesn't exactly the same as me he had
sex with Laura then had sex with me no
I'm bad smile and no one says oh what a
slag what's he done that for what a
player but because I've done it with a
man and I'm a female
how'd you every interview how to fit
your parents feel how'd you feel about
that do you regret it
are you sure no I'm not I'm a woman I
went on a dating show and I took the
experience of both hands and I'll do
that in the outside world and I'd done
it in there I'm not going to be a
different person just because there's
cameras watching me as you think it's
interesting though that words didn't get
like a single thing or Adam thing
because well I had this discussion with
I didn't interview Rita Ora and Cara
Delevingne about Beauty bullying a
couple of weeks ago and we were talking
about where do we think it will starts
from actually I think the media
it's got massive massive part to play in
it because what they love is the
downfall they don't love the rise so if
someone's rising up they want you them
to get to a certain level and then bring
them back down and I think especially
with you there be like they want to tear
women down which is crazy so I think the
discussions that media people have and
we have discussions like this all the
time because as a publication especially
as a journalist I take great pride in
being a massive feminist and I want to
empower women so every interview I do I
don't wanna catch them out I don't be
trying to get some sort of lying out
there that shames them for their
behavior I want to be like look this is
an amazing woman let's like build them
up and I feel like I think sometimes
like I'm digging myself up but I really
wish that more journalists were like
that and I think if they stopped doing
stuff like trying to drag women down and
men as well I think it would be a much
more empowering
world and I think then these girls who
were 14 will feel like it's not
justified
because if they see it in mass media
mass me just so has such a massive power
I know we talk about like it's a social
media revolution but that mass media
does enforce all those old-school
traditional values which are just
prehistoric far as I'm concerned
obviously you know the platforms on
which you're all being trolled on also
have to and are and are joining pasta
this conversation I'm very aware of it
and they're and they're bringing in
strategies and tactics to help you do
you think that they're going far enough
to help you is there some recommendation
you make to the social media platforms
that could help you in some way like
it's been going on for such a long time
or you get report abuse you report it
and does that help
why do you report abuse let's just move
on but then the horrible part is
actually didn't find you somewhere else
you block on one point and then you've
got and and also I used to get the point
we think well won't reply but then I do
want to reply so on the stand up for
myself but then when you apply they'll
screenshot it and then their tribe of
people who think the same way of them
will read it do its different me talking
to you than me typing to you can't get
the way I'm saying it and you have to be
so cautious and then it means that we
can't actually say anything back because
whatever we say it could be taken the
wrong way which is why video I find like
Instagram stories are YouTube's handy
because you can talk and you guys can
feel what I'm saying to you and I'm not
being aggressive back but it's the think
with the Instagram and and reporting
abuse they're just gonna get an
aggressive message saying or giving them
a warning and it doesn't get resolved
it's not gonna go anywhere
no do you block or do you respond
I used to respond with like really sassy
comments and then like I be like
especially play like the simple ones
like you're gay live like you were a
competition you got it right like I mean
come on like but I'm more about like now
I've come to this I know what we're
talking about as you get older as well
but my validation doesn't come from
online and that's become quite a long
like that's been a quite difficult thing
to me to come to terms with
and actually all my validation now comes
from myself and I think once you place
the validation within yourself then
those kind of people can't really get to
you anymore so I just let them lift
their hating lives on YouTube they
really want to that's how they get their
kicks they've probably got their own
problems anyway and I think that's also
a really important point because most
these people who are going online and
spreading this hey have such awful
negativity inside of them and they've
got so many problems because like when
you speak to most seventeen step like
what you do to the haters like it's come
quite a generic question for instance
and they will turn around and be like
you know I've actually engaged them and
then actually wants have engaged them I
found that they have these horrific
problems like they've had awful family
issues and they're using this as the way
to then I mean I'm not saying that's
justified because you shouldn't take
make yourself feel better by tearing
smiles down but I think there needs to
be a bit more appreciation for
everyone's back story as well I think
once we can unlock that then we can try
and to eradicate the hatred how do you
become more resilient I mean resilience
is a big topic at the moment obviously
it's not something you're born with it's
a muscle that grows how have you grown
that muscle how have you become more
resilient when I first come out the
villa literally we film the final and
then an ITV guy took me in an office and
just said write these all the negative
stories that come out about you and
there were lows like maybe 10 and he
like told me them in a space of five
minutes Artur oh my god I'm gonna leave
this little bubble and I just want to
stay here then I come out and it was
like so much negativity my mum was in
tears because obviously we couldn't
speak and she was aside so much hate
against you she's like I'm so worried
how you'd react when you came out so it
was a shock at first and I'm not gonna
lie it is like human nature you wanna
kind of even though I knew it was gonna
be all negative I did Gunn Daily Mail
comments and read it and then you think
after that day of like kind of wallowing
in self-pity and you're like okay well
that [ __ ] is not doing anything positive
so after reading that for the first
maybe
day or two we're talking like why doing
that and nothing positive comes from it
and I think like I said it's all the
same sort of comments like you're fake
you're a slag stuff like that and once
you've heard it once yeah it stings but
you can hear it a million times you're
still going to have the same effect so I
just try not to
read into it too much and I think the
more you get it the more and it is it's
a blessing and a curse I'm so grateful
to be given the love island platform and
to be able to reach I get so many
positive messages from women as well
talking about like anxiety and girls who
have worked in the sex industry and that
you make me feel normally the first
person to like speak about it and make
it like be normal so I just let the
positive outweigh the negative if I
could sit all day and feel sorry for
myself I just try and focus on the
positive what about you long how do you
become more resilient to it so hard like
every day as soon as I post something or
if someone repost me the worst one has
been someone repost my videos like those
really big viral makeup pages that
repost my videos I'll click on the
comment station there'll be like
thousands and thousands of like hiccups
I'm not over exaggerating guys it's like
so many hate comments and it's probably
like five six positive comments like oh
yeah I like it I think and then the rest
is like oh she's so annoying I blocked
her and I still see her face there's me
thinking I'm glad you see my face
because I can see it I'm sorry but you
know you can sometimes you gotta like
turn things over and kind of it's not a
joke billion is not a joke but if you
can tell yourself that you shouldn't
take this too seriously and if you can
tell yourself I should actually laugh at
this situation because they can't
physically touch you they can't meet you
in person and say this is their business
because I guarantee you 100 percent of
the time they are so scared to say to
your face they will be sick if anything
they see you they'll be like yeah
everyone on social media scare like
literally because they walk they like to
Billy's are so weird right they will
hate you but they like to use you yes
but in terms of being resilient is hard
like every day you just go heats having
years I mean go be your own best friend
and that's one of the hardest things to
do is put in yourself as be a little
selfish I'm so glad you mentioned that
be the or selfish put yourself first be
best friend give yourself a cuddle give
yourself a night off don't rely on your
boyfriend or your girlfriend or your dog
or your cat to make yourself feel good
allowing yourself have you actually got
any proper coping strategy have you been
to see a counselor if you read books on
it this is to all of you have you spoken
to friends what do you do what's the
kind of practical tips that you could
show other people who might experience
this that they could take away from this
I actually had it I got a counsellor
this year not for social media or for
balloon but I found that we worked
through other issues and things but I
found that now it's saying I can talk to
talk to her about actually sometimes it
is just nice to talk to someone and say
look this is happening and then they'll
be like how ridiculous how stupid and
it's happening to this person that
person and and the other thing I've
realized is when someone does say a
negative comment and it hurts it hurts
because I'm there's some part of me that
believes it so I had to address those
things that people are saying I think no
okay look I know what I'm doing is right
and I'm gonna sit down talk about it and
then I can then share more information
as to why I know this isn't true that
that kind of thing but I think the main
thing I did was ask for help from other
people so don't suffer in silence when
you do feel like it's just becoming
overwhelming especially when you're
young and you're at school I definitely
don't not tell anybody if that's
happening and like you know print screen
it save it so you can prove that it's
there if you need to and speak to an
adult and then when you become an adult
and you're where we are just talk to
your friends and and sometimes like if
someone does posting horrendous I'll put
it on Twitter and be like guys it's got
this one today and the whole world will
be like
down thumbs and or even on YouTube
actually if you get a negative comment I
don't show you've had it your followers
will just put the thumbs down on it and
it's going to show you yeah and I love
the time they've even had it today
someone just mention me was like I hate
you and I was like that's that familiar
oh my gosh I love you you replied no I
was like okay so a lot of it is just
nonsense people just not thinking so
yeah asking for help but definitely say
it's just the best thing that I ever did
and and then the ones that read you get
to you like maybe the thumb or the nose
or whatever it is think why is this an
issue and try and fix that which we've
all done by getting our teeth fixed and
[Laughter]
I think actually I mean this is not
contrary to what you're saying if I do
you think you should speed people if you
have
you experience anything like this but
the biggest lesson for me is learning to
rely on myself actually and like you
were saying learning to become your own
best friend because once I become
comfortable in myself then I can't take
on anyone's negative energy and that's
something I've been really looking at
doing over say about the last six months
I don't take on anyone's energy anymore
like if you've got I just think it's
your it's your issue like for instance
if some one of my friends has an issue
I'm like that's your problem like
obviously if I've been if I've been
negative or it's my fault
then I'm the first person to sit there
and go look I'm really sorry for that
but if someone's gonna come at me with
any kind of like energy that isn't
welcome inside my space I'm like that's
your issue is fine I'll be like on to
the next thing and I think that's
something that I've really learned in
say like the last yeah and that's been
the most valuable lesson I've learned be
it with your friends your family at work
be online I think that is the most
biggest lesson to take away especially
in this industry I think everyone's got
an opinion and I think just having like
a bluetick or so many followers or being
on reality show having a successful
YouTube channel people think that these
comments won't hurt you we're still a
person and we still go home and get in
bed at night thinking oh well that was a
bit [ __ ] was it you know it doesn't mean
we're like yeah it is hard but yeah just
be a bit selfish as I see around social
medias a huge conversation has it given
any of you anxiety really bad like kids
like two and a half to three years ago I
dropped out of uni I didn't have a
proper job I wasn't really working I was
doing like little bartending jobs just
so like help me get by I was lying I was
relying on my boyfriend a lot in terms
of finances I had to move up my mom's
because there was a lot of family issues
and like that was a really dark tunnel
so when I started to use Instagram as an
escape route to do like makeup videos I
don't want to be a makeup vlogger I
don't know what I was doing I was just
using Instagram makeup videos as a way
to escape from all the negative
see that was already going on in my life
so when my videos decide to get more
recognition and I was going through this
you know the cyber billiard it just
brought me down so much more and it's
like you don't know what that person is
going through you don't know where that
person came from you don't know if that
person is struggling to buy dinner
because that was me so like to do these
videos on my platform and to have loads
of people cussed me for my looks on my
skin for my hair for my race and then
there's me thinking like what the hell
like I really I'm already struggling
like by food I'm already getting this so
yeah you ever suffered anxiety from it
Josh well you in the past but certainly
not now not now but I don't think it's
ever really made me feel anxious it's
just it's made me feel sad but I feel
like sadness and anxiety very different
things
I'm not very an anxious person anyway
I've always been very resilient and I
think basic I would say the resilience
is the thing that is my key thing
resilient in everything I've ever done
is being resilient and being dog
determined so I never really have let it
cause me epic at amounts of anxiety I
would say for me I've always on and off
suffered with like depression anxiety
and for me the biggest thing is when I'm
having a down day when I'm not feeling
good don't go and look for it to then
punish myself further I find myself
doing that a lot if I had a bad day and
I Bly not good I'll be like we'll go
read it then because you deserve to read
it all these comments are true and then
was a block why why are you doing that
you're just feeding into it so I think
it's i opening like before I was very
are single for three years and I would
have these habits and coping mechanisms
but living with someone else see it can
really help you
so I think the fact if you having a down
day have a day off for social media you
don't have to have it every single day
and even from my job Garrett's useful
when I'll have deadlines to me and post
a post but if priority again be selfish
like look after yourself first we're not
in the villa it was the best I ever ever
felt and that was no social media strip
back no money no material things no like
designer bag design
you and other people and it's the happy
stuff felt amazing because people just
took it you're like oh she's on TV but
they don't yeah well they don't really
feel it she's interesting
okay I'm gonna wrap up now before we go
get some questions but before I do and
none of you know about this a lot from
you Josh I'm gonna do a very quick fire
round I'm gonna give you an option a
dilemma and I just went to Tom it's very
easy it's a lot of fun I just want to
tell me what your thoughts are so first
of all Instagram or YouTube little
Instagram Instagram YouTube
strictly x-factor Shapley is we kind of
thing there was like I still watch
exercise
Oh Kendall this is like Sophie's Choice
I'm gonna go with Kylie rapper covergirl
Jeremy Corbyn or Theresa May - I'm gonna
go with Teresa just cuz she's Brazilian
that's the only thing good takeaway
she's very Brazilian i'll pass i'm not
cooed up on this and lastly mistletoe or
wine wine this will talk right now wine
in the bucketload the mystery do
I'm gonna go mistletoe and he's there
with you
to be continued and hope is Matt's wine
the mistletoe okay we know who's under
the mistletoe with you Sir Tom Hardy's
around thank you so much for sharing
your stories with us today it's been
really enlightening and hopefully
helpful to everybody watching this we're
going to open it for some questions
there's anybody got any questions they'd
like to ask so I'm just gonna repeat
that question because they didn't hear
it so the question was are you ever your
own bully yeah I've been followed a lot
of people in my time as well because I
encourage a lot of people to like I used
to find before I liked myself as much as
I do now that I would kind of follow
people in the hopes of being more like
them I think and I when I realized just
how when I was scrolling through things
or watching things it was giving me such
a negative feeling when I realized if I
just clicked unfollow
and it wasn't therefore it was all my
fault um I felt so much better
so I do say to a lot of my followers
just you know might be for like a day or
for a week or for a year that person's
not done anything but there's something
that's going on between you and that
person isn't making you feel good and if
they're not making you feel good they
don't want to make you feel bad so it
I'm kind of unfollowing then maybe come
back later that's definitely one thing I
found myself doing more of I wouldn't
say I don't know sometimes can push in
yourself because fighters billion I
don't know cause like sometimes I don't
know yeah like sometimes I mean it's
coming from like my parents because my
parents always pushed me to work really
really hard like sometimes I'll stay up
to like 5:00 6:00 in the morning and I
won't see people for months just working
on YouTube and Instagram and I don't
want to classify that as Billy and I
want to classify that as just being way
too hard on yourself so ignore me it's a
very valid point I think we're a lot of
us do that like I said I've always
suffered from anxiety and I think in
itself that's not feeling good about
yourself so even sitting here I get
nervous and that I can't set up there
with all these people and talk in front
of a roomful of people so I think always
not feeling good enough is something and
then when other people are telling you
that as well it just feeds into that so
yeah I've always that's why I just try
not to read it because it is just like
fuel in the fire and like the little
insecurities in my mind that's why I
think coming off for even a day or half
now or if you like just feeling a bit
[ __ ] go out go for a run walk around
like do something that like fills your
heart pack more than looking for these
comments and something because the end
of the day social media is just people's
highlights people aren't going to put on
social media you know I just want yeah I
just want run the park and step in dog
[ __ ] now I was gonna say that it's gonna
put all these highlights so if you're
not feeling good about yourself get off
if you could go back to one of your
darkest times and give yourselves an
emergency piece of advice what would it
be
we talked through the situation that's
giving them my anxiety almost a cup a
rehearsal we'll go do it so this kind of
thing freaks me out to confront people
but I've done it so many times in my
head that it's okay or so for example
when I was really freaking out about
posting a video of me doing the workout
pregnant I was like okay well I'm gonna
show it to my mum she loved it great
this is fine it's up there and it
okay I think one thing you just know
that if you can run through like a
rehearsal it already takes out a lot of
the fear because you already know you
can do it and then it's just doing it
and we're all here from all of these
darkest moments that we've all had we're
all here and every day it gets easier I
think definitely I think my advice if I
was to go back in time if I could go
back to that three years ago
well we're struggling I would let you
tell myself you will be okay your whole
entire family will rely on you and I
think that's why I would say to myself
yeah I mean the best piece of advice I
ever got was I was working at Topshop
and I was like sixteen and the girl said
to me I think in life is transient and
that's got me through so many difficult
times because I always just think how I
feel now it's not how I gonna fill in a
day it's not how I'm gonna feel a little
weak it's not how I'm gonna feel in a
month or a year or ten years and I also
you now feel like I've disliked
five-year raw so if I know that some I
think will this bother me in five years
and I think if it doesn't it's not worth
my time if it does then I take it on and
address it but I think that's the most
viable piece of I sort of give myself
yeah and then you'll excuse like bye bye
Felicia don't need this anymore it's
great it's the best thing so liberating
because you just don't panic
yeah I just think the same location
thing like it will get better it will
you can't always be like I wouldn't be
here now if I would've been
self-indulgent for I'm resigned to
failure I'm anxious I'm nervous I don't
know whatever wasted so many years of my
life I would have still been in a pub
drinking this a friend I would have been
on Lovelight and I won't be here so it
will get there and I feel like we spread
more positive
and this is what I feel really good
messed up you guys circus I got to New
York like a month and so I think
especially what you've done like turning
all this notice you can mix you up on
within yourself and come at home it
might come out here and showing girls
and guys regardless of gender as well
but there's so much positive to take
from negativity I just what I just say
back so just thinking of the days have
you ever shared anything on social media
that in retrospect you wish you hadn't
because of the backlash that ensued I
think the thing with social media is
it's an amazing platform you never know
what you're gonna do is gonna have upset
one person or maybe you know you didn't
know a back story on something or what
you just never know what's gonna trigger
people and I think we've probably I know
I've had moments where I've shared
something that I've thought this is epic
and then it's turned out to be an
absolute lie that someone else was
created and that happens a lot and you
kind of feel the fire was like well you
join in on something that everyone
really cares about but you're one tweet
is the one that everyone goes hit like
hammer for I think yes social media it
does make you think a little bit more
before you join in on something because
one it could go swings and roundabouts
very very quickly for me it's sharing my
beliefs
so like I'm against like racism and
doing it and all of that so if I was to
ever talk about it I would just get [ __ ]
for it
seriously I just get so much [ __ ] for it
but it's like it's just so annoying it's
like I could stand up for the LGBT
community and then someone be like but
you're not lesbian so how can you speak
for us I'm just like I'm here to support
you I could I donate a lot of my makeup
products to like different types of
charities if I was to say that on social
media if I was to be specific what type
of charity is someone be like what about
this charity why don't you help them out
and it's like I am trying my best to
help every single person out there
leaveme I do try my best my head you
just can't win I just think like
someone's gonna hate something like you
probably get some thirsty boy send you a
message if you post a topless picture
then you probably get someone being like
put your body away and you've got your
man-machine like what you do in like so
I feel like there's always there's
always different horses of different
courses I would say yeah
God please them all but definitely I
would say regret definitely comes after
I've been on my hour and I posted
something and it's nice you just may be
my friend dancing around the pole and
then your boss late you have a casual
night last night that you're like no no
references but um but no I think maybe
I'd become bit more worried about being
more South edited I would say I
definitely don't talk about politics
ever ever ever ever part from tonight
yeah well I was more saying for the
resilience because I'm I remind the
resilience but not necessarily
everything else yeah one I got a comment
like a hate comment from a lady and then
I posted itch that I can't get over how
much of a [ __ ] no I can't handle how
much of a slap you ask the nice
screenshot that put it on my story ice I
was good job Wes can handle how much
force like I am a just like now I'm
getting bullied all your cuz I have like
one point now you say all your followers
are now messaging me and it's like what
you said earlier you don't know
someone's backstory she could have been
having a really [ __ ] day I don't know
her story she's come back from work
she's seen now for oh your ass leg and
just typed out of anger and then I've
gone added two more so I did regret that
but that was like early days of coming
out and I just Lily go
she's such a crazy thing though because
I feel like it's still something that
people have a go at people about but
being sexually empowered we had
discussion we did the Gwyneth Paltrow
interview and we had to run our cover
and she talked quite openly about
empowering women and how it's great that
women are having all healthy orgasm as
it needs to a healthy life and then
people would tear into her for it
I mean like why is it so
negative that women are so in control
the sexuality and I think people still
find it scary but I also think that
comes from a very jealous place as well
[Music]
last question so the question is do you
think that help and advice is best comes
from influences or panels and talks like
this in terms of dealing with Beauty
bullying I think it needs to come from
all angles to be honest and I always
think it needs to come from mic as soon
as you're born you no need to meet
educated how to be nice to other people
and I think a filter has been lost by us
having so many filters I would never
dream of talking to people the way that
we've been spoken to it's just not
something would ever happen to mean I'm
sure most of you guys would never dream
of right saying these things or thinking
these things so something has been lost
with those people and I think it's
something with the parents and teachers
for us on live everybody to just cuz it
guys people have feelings for me not
talk that way if the same as you haven't
got something nice to say then don't say
anything at all that was what I had as a
kid and I think we just need to
reinstall that people need I think it's
just for you met that filter having a
bit more respect for people I'm thinking
before you say something and I'm
especially we have this platform which
means we don't have to think before we
say it but it has really negative
complications afterwards so yeah I think
just break the filter a little bit I
think a furnace is a really massive
issue in humanity in general because I
think there's always gonna be a pat
mentality where you're gonna change like
fight off the weak species or whatever
like that is human nature it's in
grading human nature I think until I
think the major issue that schools need
stress is this subject of other nurse
and I think everyone should talk about
that be like there's no such thing as an
offer we're all human beings we're all
entitled to be on this earth regardless
of sexual orientation race whether
you've had sex on TV whether you haven't
like I feel like there needs to be more
discussion amongst parents especially
but like you were saying I think it has
to be a 360 approach and I think it has
to come up with angles and I think
making sure kylie jenner's talking about
it is amazing she's talked about it then
having
like a news story on the 6 o'clock news
is amazing maybe like some of the same
facts I've heard about Beauty bullying
that like 16 million posts its new to
Georgia Beauty building every year like
it's insane those need to become
headlines it needs to become a
discussion I think through discussing it
we can work out our differences and
address them well I'd like to say on
something I haven't said yes is that our
campaign has been in association with
the diner award and they offer amazing
help for online cyberbullying and there
were charities out there there were
experts there were people to talk to and
I think really for as individuals who
aren't lucky enough to be here tonight
or can't meet with the panel like this
to help
I think definitely those help lines and
charities like the diner order
definitely the people to turn to for
some help help and advice and some
resilience and tactics and I think you
know small acts of kindness and
supporting people who that you see are
being bullied online goes a long way
thank you so much you've been absolutely
[Applause]